SCP-682 Vs SCP-938.
Can this electrical entity provide an adequate
shock to 682’s system?
SCP-682 was placed in a containment chamber
attached to Site-07.
An electric device was brought into the room
and routed into SCP-938.
The device increased in electrical voltage
to the point that it damaged SCP-682, causing
burns to its body and paralyzing it for one
hour.
At this point, it regained motion capabilities
and shot electricity from its spine through
its head.
Then, it lost consciousness - though it was
still breathing - and remained that way for
several days as its body recovered.
Not quite as electrifying as the Foundation
had hoped, so it appeared.
The researcher for this test, Dr. Carly, did
at least note that electrical or mind-based
SCPs did tend to keep SCP-682 immobilized
longer than physical or chemical attacks.